[Applaudissements]
le monde
il a de très très demandant qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
y a du cgi les oscars les oscars je suis
fan phocéenne oscars les oscars a fait
un petit point sur les ventes nettes
laurent weil et didier allouch ça c'est
monde c'est ma passé les grands retours
ça passe on serre les grands retours des
pronostics de montaigne
j'adore la du bambino statcan graphiste
j'adore la la gracieuse jeu ce spectacle
m'a dit fais togolais tire le rideau
s'ouvre c'est à toi c'est ta scène elle
se ça vous dirait les 24 heures tv pour
son jaillit bien sûr allez on change hi
eric il a envie de songer à verdi en
short rêver tout ce qu'il ne fallait pas
rater la télé heure par heure au cours
de ce dernier week-end regarder ça
allait partir
[Musique]
je suis un petit ménage encore tf1
hashtag anarchiste j'en ai profité pour
mater les 12 coups de midi ou une
candidate ne connaît pas le mot gambas
au singulier comment se prononce le mot
gamba et crevettes
bon alors pas de crevettes j'ai regardé
les marseillais sur w9 regarder après
avoir fait le tour du monde ils sont
toujours aussi de calais en géographie
ça fait plaisir
elle a trouvé le souci des jamais c'est
le koala non maintenant hâte de les voir
pour de vrai il appelle une vie qui
s'appelle points à la longue
sur national geographic en interviewer
un maître de chien surdoué
visiblement monsieur narcoleptique aussi
[Musique]
s'est juste endormi à d'envoi hier à
midi que caroline delage est revenu sur
la cérémonie des césars quelque chose me
dit que je n'ai pas l'hyper cinoche
aucun animée par manu payet le sens de
la fête de nakache et toledano avec
jean-pierre batterie est nommé venir ici
j'ai trouvé deux fois les jeux malin
mais les plus indignes du web ou est-ce
que tu trouve tout ça c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
évidemment non
j'adorais la central saint martins greg
on parlera des césars dont je parle aux
comédiens et phrases courtes ça passe
mal on tient un truc j'ai encore maté
toute la télé c'est vraiment beaucoup de
temps ça m'a obligé de lâcher les
poteaux du saïan supa crew tu dois
bosser la clavicule jours du salon de
l'agriculture bfm en a profité pour
interviewer des organisateurs vont être
contents c'est le délire il a même battu
le record du nombre de places âge dumont
record vous allez comprendre les gens il
reste mon ami records encore les dunes
la salon records d'une édition record on
a eu je pense un nombre record
d'exposants et on peut dire vraiment
qu'on a fait
très très bon salon pour ne pas dire un
salon ressort à 3,15 et en direct depuis
le salon avec un public hyper attentif
s'offrent un élève de 4e 14 sorties
scolaires et lui cherche absolument à se
faire repérer pour ses talents de mime
je me retire place au talent vous
imaginez pas prof quand on a préparé
cette émission
vous êtes le prof de zootechnie
troisième technique de mots c'est quoi
c'est ma biologie tour du monde
complètement par hasard le gîte et s en
interviewer l'homme le plus gentil de la
planète y restent y perdre et ans quand
il se prend une boule de neige en pleine
tête regardez une carte postale a
immortalisé bat montpellier la nage
c'est pas souvent donc faut en profiter
la dernière fois je crois que c'était il
ya 4 5 ans la nage
suite de l'interview il est vraiment
trop cool il a perturbé
c'est vrai que la neige ça complique un
peu mais il faut voir le bon côté des
choses parce que ça m'a aussi ont baissé
mon fut donc après pour les voitures
c'est galère l'évolution est un sport
c'est des banques a dit tu as des
changes l'euro campe ouet africaine
j'étais invité aux césars où j'ai maté
slam sur france3 rabattent donc pas
hésité à qui fait pas du web aux césar
on aussi jacques thomas huges allait pas
bien sûr moi j'adorais sur moi j'aime
pas ça parce que patron est juste là que
j'ai une place de parking
mais après il en a pas ici au parc à huy
sur paris on a d'ailleurs des proches on
n'est pas un parking
l'histoire nous regarde je me mets au
jeu tout à fait dans votre jeunesse vous
avez c'est moïse ça s'ouvre franchement
je vais quitter le plateau
vas-y fais ton truc moi j'ai pas
regretter de mater slam parce qu' un
truc qu'on adore avec cyril c'est qu'il
ya cyril féraud qu'encore planta un
candidat sur un plateau à la fin la
musique qui part de slam et il adore
faire à être saluée il est un gars mal à
l'aise sur son plateau là dedans il doit
faire semblant d'être cool sur de la
musique mais tu te rends vite compte que
les candidates sam le samedi c'est plus
battle de uno que papagayo sont mis dans
l'ambiance plus tôt
tap le père
non
ouais dans les marseillais tiens il ya
carla qui a blessé deux bibliothécaires
en passant l'expression amuser la
galerie je sais car là c'est pas votre
délire cyril est clairement de toi donc
je sais pas si c'est sincère si vraiment
il a envie d'aller vers juillard ou si
finalement il fait pour retarder la
galanterie calories et ce week-end se
sont déroulés les championnats du monde
d'athlétisme animée par patrick
nostradamus m'appelle j'adore l'occasion
de voir qu'il a toujours autant de
pistes dans ses pronostics
20e pour l'instant peu forcément mieux
faire les ingrédients il est aussi aux
seelandais smac carte est peut-être un
petit billet sur sur le britannique
[Applaudissements]
le ticket j'ai regardé bas le comédien
jean mi temps j'ai regardé la 90e
cérémonie des oscars ça passe
ouais pour ceux qui connaissent pas
c'est comme les babas au poste mais aux
états unis on avait plein de choses
parce que j'adore ça c'est mon dit plein
de beau monde sur le tapis rouge ça fait
rêver regarder salma hayek rayonnant
belle comme toi elle était là on a 4 ans
et steven spielberg
enfin sandra bullock était présente
aussi nicole kidman qu'a pris le temps
de poser pour les photographes
on a aussi vu la chanteuse andrade et
développement qui s'est cru dans la
dernière pub château d'ax
on a vu gilles verdez incognito avec une
nouvelle coupe c'est rapide et là hop en
blond s'est pas dégagé des gueules on a
trouvé le gars qui a des manches de
smoking les plus courtes hollande on
sait pas pourquoi on dirait qu'il a
pleuré pour la voir on sait pas pourquoi
c'est très petit mais c'est les états
unis dont tout le monde trouve ça
toujours mieux les oscars qu'en france
alors que parlons l'estimé des images de
chez nous du gouvernement c'est tout
aussi frère
[Musique]
c'est parti c'est de la folie sur le
tapis rouge les quatre insight et
dicaprio on va les voir dans l'instant
oui je pense titanic l'histoire et que
cela nécessite une centaine 63 euros
qu'on a vu son roc en train d'arriver
mairie il mérici est arrivé 21e
nomination pour mériter de retour en
direct avec jackie chan qui est avec le
[Applaudissements]
milieu de paris l'a d'ailleurs juste
après la perte amant et leonardo
dicaprio un sursis
oui catch me if you can chaque jour
j'adore les films préférés aussi
dangereux sont dans le bon sens mais bon
c'est pas gagné je sais pas si vous le
savez mais en anglais m avant ça se dit
didier louis ix oscar dit didier et
laurent weil sur canal vous le savez
pour le red carpet on les adore mais
pour elle c'est vrai que meryl streep et
dicaprio ils connaissent pas des masses
didier allouch donc ils ont encore passé
la soirée à essayer d'arrêter des gens
pourra voir l'interview mais adam foote
adore ça m'excite de timon non on en
parle est passé
son interview matthew matthew dit oui
nle tomas j cole a dit le président
je vais peut-être revenir garrigues
ariary le paiement - pour canal+ gary
demande mot qui revient le revenu j'ai
déjà entendu celle là et ça s'appelle
avant et wii 2 août 140 de refus ils ont
réussi à voir quelqu'un fronçait bien
sûr alexandre desplat l'oscar de la
meilleure musique et didier tellement
surpris que quelqu'un s'arrête en fait
il n'avait pas préparé donc il se fait
reprendre en direct qui n'importe quoi
quant à alexandre de ce plat il est
maintenant temps encore alexandre
comment ça va c'est encore moins encore
nous et il va faire les poches s'il vous
plaît note 9 et voilà
on adore j'ai bien joué franchement ils
se lancèrent alors je les adore ses 13
enfants tellement laurent weil
maintenant il fait du stand up carré
mais aux autres car il fait sa phase de
stand-up directement depuis là-bas ils
enchaînent didier l'écoutent même plus
quand il fait ses vannes place aux
comics culte
ben disons belattar c'est un type qui
filme ben moi j'aime beaucoup mais c'est
raide et en gardera un passionnant
cameron textos mais plutôt de la riviera
qui montrent si j'ai pas trop déçu pour
aller voir la scission le l'a déçu
bonjour varda pépito pépito bebeto
amicaux la salle pépy dans ses traits
mexicain toute façon ce soir donc
qu'est-ce qu'on adore comme petite
question dit elle lui s'estime des
anecdotes son coût de ces les anecdotes
chez paou y vas tu comprends plus haut
doubs il ya didier au lycée il a pris
morini-bosc lv2 à mon époque et alors %
par deux séries télé il ya un moment
assez rigolo on a vu le rythme et de
qualité à ses côtés il y avait une jeune
femme blonde c'est sa fille et laurie
metcalf pour ceux qui aiment les séries
télé elle joue la mère de sheldon dans
the big bang theory et dans l'yonne
sheldon et la série 2-2
de celle de big bang theory qui raconte
l'historien quand il était jeune
celle qui joue la mère du petit sheldon
c'est la fille de laurie metcalf combien
de barda elle était tout et de rien et
voilà c'est une petite anecdote qui
aurait beaucoup plu à jérôme commandeur
fait engueuler un petit peu des césar
quand même on a regardé les césars aussi
l'occasion pour notre ministre de la
culture françoise nyssen de partager sa
passion pour le cinéma français
on voit qu'elle rate aucun film et s'est
couché est important vous avez eu des
coups de coeur au cinéma cette année
la dispute liste add on à la susdite en
permanence
plein d'autres bien sûr des mauvaises
gens qu'elle adore le cinéma notre
ministre à la passe et super soirée
regardez comme elle s'éclate avec gérald
liste et voila je sais que vous les
connaissez pas mais moi je vous aime
beaucoup mais elle dort un petit peu là
l'a fait une petite sieste
cette année encore c'était vraiment les
films festif et légers qui ont été
récompensé aux césar
une vie de la tête devant la cérémonie
ça fait un bien fou harrison fils et
nous en coûte en train de divorcer qu'on
aura déjà leur avenir l'un sans l'autre
fils et son frère brisé depuis la mort
de sa famille vit en inde deux cortèges
sont partis sans troupeau est menacé par
une épidémie pour que la mort de son
grand-père
le pitch de cuivre d'or de la soirée
c'est celui-là je fonce voir ce film dès
ce soir qui n'a ni à son gilet dirai
jamais renner est le premier réalisateur
remporté par deux fois ce césar c'est un
programme de tournée kraton lequel en
renard se prend pour une foule en a
peint fait la cigogne en gare de
remplacer le père noël
[Applaudissements]
on suit avec un petit truc ce que tu
veux on se quitte avec une artiste qui
pour moi va tout cartonner c'est la
future star de la chanson seul problème
elle fait à la guitare voix c'est
magnifique mais la mauvaise cordes qui
pète sa réponse
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]